he's impotent  Tessa become a severe storm it's a stay  and very calm belong to a male amassed a  mean commit circuit show so people  in the motel face of beat down  thirty-six minutes ago we got an evac  distress signal from Air Force one you  think this is the most serious terrorist  action since 9/11 is this some kid I'm  talking to who are you President of the  United States prove it any suggestions  find the president dilma zones and  [ __ ] who are after him  primo big game hunting never got any  bigger you found me you rescued me water  elevator you protected me  I  believing you have to be tough  allemande left his toys off what the  Buckeyes in the way  yes